in other developments today than
Britain's opposition Labour Party is
demanding an investigation into
coronavirus deaths in elderly care homes
which it describes as being mishandled
about a quarter of the country's covert
fatalities have happened in residential
facilities Labour's deputy leader says
people have been tragically let down
should be there should be some
investigation into that and Kier stammer
has requested that because every single
death is tragic and we've had medical
experts answer whoever said we seeded
the virus into our care homes and the
guidance wasn't there for care workers I
think they've been tragically like down
on Friday it was revealed a number of
care home residents in Britain who died
from the coronavirus was actually 50%
higher than previously estimated the new
data emerged after the prime minister
was called out over what the Labour
leader described as unexplained deaths
the new research has revealed there been
more than 12,000 Cova Dru lated deaths
in elderly residential facilities since
the beginning of March we talked to
Michelle Rowland who lost her mother
mum's got a temperature and a call and
then they sort of advised me that she
had had a call for the day before as
well as I said well these are very
symptomatic of the the coronavirus or
cope at 19 or ever has she been tested
no we're not testing I was a oh okay the
preceding days basically on the Friday
night I get a call going we've got the
tests back she's been tested for Coby at
19 and the tests come back positive it's
really horrible because she can't go and
see them you cannot hold their hand
you can't look after them you can't you
know anything I have to really pretty
much black my way to get to speak to my
mom on the go and that was the last time
and we talked about the day what we were
looking forward to it when the weather
was going to get warmer
and we were going to get her in a chair
and get her outside and she was so
looking forward to it
Monday morning 10 o'clock phone call
from the care home say the mom had
passed away the ones who talked to me
more I couldn't then of course it's not
only a problem in the UK and the United
States around a third of all coronavirus
deaths are among residents or even staff
in the country's 7,700 care facilities
America journalists and regular RT
contributor Dave Lindell told us about
the loss of his mother-in-law to covert
19 at a care home in New Jersey my
mother-in-law had dementia so you know
she needs to be in care like that
unfortunately when the infection started
to spread around the nursing homes all
over the country including where my
mother-in-law was they ended up with a
hundred and the last time I looked at a
hundred and fourteen patients infected
out of 150 patients
that's that basically everybody there
and they didn't have masks for adequate
masks where the nurses were for the
patients so there was really no way to
keep it from spreading the infections
really should never have happened and
that's I think a really hard thing to
live with that that the reason they
happened you knew was because the
nursing homes didn't have the adequate
tests to be able to isolate people who
had it from people who didn't the
nursing homes were getting second
priority for distribution of the
available tests and the masks so they
went first hospitals and I see use
because they had so few 70% of the
nursing homes to run as for-profit part
they're owned by for-profit corporations
and so they're squeezing the the
staffing in order to keep the profits up
and the costs down and that's another
reason why this is so bad
you